[Music]
and lazy solution news Oh tell me the
details of those submitted by boys to
babies boys - boys - man oh yeah
an inventor created the world's first
self-cleaning house because she was sick
of cleaning up I need this [ __ ] that's
so finally I've been waiting for this
it's from a woman of course it would be
from a woman I can't believe innovation
what I think laziness I think guys I
don't think good for some reason oh I
was thinking like I can't believe
innovation came from one well she knows
what needs to be cleaned so that's
actually a good thing
sarcasm yeah my wife is messy lady ah
what no I'm being completely serious
don't say that
or she could write it in pen right now
and write forever new t-shirt yeah so
Frances Gabe she invented the
self-cleaning home let me see this
[ __ ] it took ten years of work
probably not [ __ ] this a decade of
planning right so it took 20 years
during that time I was just collecting
so much [ __ ] garbage her house was
not getting cleaned up [ __ ] now that
shit's outdated you know does that room
but [ __ ] work yes I have one it's the
best thing every way you swear does it
mop floors oh no a vacuum Mike I have a
dog so I never ever have to sleep I told
you you were so against the Roomba she
wanted to vacuum all on her arm like
you're wasting time when we use money
to save time you gotta let technology do
the work we shouldn't be doing the work
we need to own sleep tell me it's cuz
you don't trust machines tell me it's
good I'll have your back on this one
what do you think sure a [ __ ] robot
is gonna come out of the Roomba and
[ __ ] rape us and [ __ ] no my main
reasoning is that our apartment is
really small I mean the dogs are gonna
be in there like barking at it and like
getting in its way your apartments
bigger than my house well that's true
but the number one reason I want a
Roomba is because I wanted to [ __ ] with
my cat's I thought like it would keep
the dogs company because they'll be now
like burnt pork and then before they
knew it it's like when we got home
instead of being bored all day like hmm
and you still my dog doesn't care for it
but the worst thing about having the
Roomba is that whenever I'm working
editing or doing something it turns on
and then I go press the button and then
redock it and it goes back to the
[ __ ] docking station right so every
day I would have to to turn it off and
do that scheduling I'm sorry you're mad
you're vacuum and it works on its own
then I changed the schedule to when I'm
not home but when it's going off at home
my alarm is on and it [ __ ] hits the
doors and then alarm goes off so right
now it's like I don't even use it
[Music]
because I do too much work all the time
yeah you don't get consistent advice I
wanna see if it were give me a pro's and
con's
all right pros and cons it's actually
pretty dope but we never use it cuz the
Samsung was like even the room but it
can't climb stairs
can I have three floors Oh stories can
you buy three no that's a waste of money
because I never use it my cats are
scared of it they're just we're not that
dirty like yeah bring it next time I'm
gonna test that out if there's good
remote control - so you could do like
like point it somewhere and I'll go
there see what it is is that it if use
at one time you probably won't see how
good it is if it's on once a day
you see it's spotless we [ __ ] about
rudaba's not being able climb stairs but
when they take over the earth we're
gonna be real thankful they can't go up
the stairs that's all I gotta say yeah I
would get you but these damn stairs
again yes it is that so Francis
completed her house in the 80s so this
is old news you know what we're talking
about this is because the New York Times
recently wrote a piece on her and so now
we're talking about that way she started
this in the 60s it was just ten years I
said digging twice it was only ten years
it took she got this idea in the 70s
after she was cleaning jam that was
running down from her wall because of
her kids and she was just so pissed one
day that she'd just grabbed the garden
hose and just started spraying on the
wall and then that's when she got an
idea that's awesome I thought you were
gonna say she was so pissed she beat the
[ __ ] out of her kids yeah my mind went
there no so she ended up inventing and
so as she created this home I'm gonna
show you guys a quick clip of back in
the day when she was showing off her
house that was the 1960s it was
completed in the 80s she was that old in
the eighties already she died at a
hundred and one years old yeah you know
why cuz she got the clean [ __ ]
she has she died last year
Francis Gabe is an inventor and her
prized invention is the self-cleaning
house kitchen it's the only operational
part of the self-cleaning house right
now and then finally the demonstration
of the self-cleaning kitchen in the
self-cleaning house dang look at all
those big sprinklers oh and there you
have it a clean kitchen Francis Gabe
style when she finds the time she'll
finish the house ahead of its time
washing housework right down the drain
wait absolutely talking about that's an
invention you put a strict sprinkler on
in her house and that's an invention yes
I'm thoroughly disappointed like a large
dishwasher and pretty much the house and
how does it dry it has warm air that
blows by the heaters inside so basically
you just can't have anything that's wood
in there so a lot of the furniture was
coated like with plastic or like all her
little knickknacks are kept in display
cases electrical outlets are covered the
bed was kept drive
I an awning that would go over it before
the washing would start her furniture
was encased in acrylic resin and then
the floors were coated with multiple
layers of marine varnish so everything's
hard as [ __ ] inside that I've never been
more disappointed in my I saw hope with
you too and I'm like cool and then I
thought I'm like well cause it's from
like the 70s or the 80s were never like
obviously everything back then was
pretty lame but I think the cool thing
is reinvention AIDS we put we put a man
on the moon
dan okay uh or did we I'm kidding I
think she's great
because I felt like relaxed while I was
watching it I [ __ ] hate cleaning like
I get anxiety when it no and I have to
start cleaning things and putting things
in order
it took us what like seven hours or
something to clean that room yeah most
of it one room did you say you have a
small apartment I know well it's because
when we moved I just got everything else
and I put it in that Lisa Walker's oh
dude like one whole room look like the
hoarder you're exaggerating I'm not
exaggerating my mom's are [ __ ]
hoarded I'm not a hoarder
I'm just the club that you called your
mom a [ __ ] I would I would call my mom
I'd be the first person to calm down you
don't get to call my mom a [ __ ] because
I get so called a war but that's true
that true it's not a better liar so I'll
defend her on that no yeah no my mom was
a 100% hoarder she's always been a [ __ ]
[ __ ] all did this [ __ ] woman will
take things that are meaningful to me I
she'll throw it away in the trash to my
face it's [ __ ] terrible dude like
I'll have like trophies from like Tech
one knowing she loves what is this oh
that's my tickler no trophies she goes
she chucked it in the garbage can I was
like right in front of me she goes what
are you gonna do with it my grandpa
would do the same thing he would take my
trophy he would throw it in the
and I'd be like what are you doing with
a grandpa and he's like ah she's tended
to the [ __ ] Smithsonian basically
what two ways of telling you what you
did is garbage and nobody gives a [ __ ]
like and and and II visually number
three he's also like I have a sense of
humor when he didn't crack though that's
what was great about you didn't he
didn't lose his uh yeah it's like duty
nobody nobody gives a [ __ ] about your
stupid karate trophy you [ __ ] where
kid comes home with a crayon he's like
this [ __ ] sucks it's not even on the
line
my dad [ __ ] threw away like my
mountain bike and because I had him I
didn't write it in like like almost six
or seven months you know do you need
this I was like well yeah I'm gonna
write it every now and then right he
goes you don't need this and I was like
it's my [ __ ] bike like let me keep my
bike round he goes he starts yelling at
me he's like my dad was fat I'm fat
you're gonna be fat yeah he takes it
just Chuck's it throws away the garbage
can and literally the next the next day
my like where's your bike I was like dad
threw it away he goes she was in the
house sleeping he was at night
I just came outside to my dad in the
garage he chucked my [ __ ] bike oh
yeah my mother why'd you throw away his
bike he doesn't use it she goes he does
you every now just cuz you don't see it
like what
did you get out of it doesn't know Mike
he had to buy me a new one and it wasn't
even a new one it was a bucket old one
speed
you know the hipsters ride and nobody
want that [ __ ] at a ten-year-old you
can't go to mounds with that yeah you
want a mound bike or be a Mack yeah so I
got like this old antique bike that was
a one speed and a beach cruiser yeah
like God what is my lesson yeah
waiting for my lesson I hope you guys
enjoyed this video for more please
subscribe to our Channel and you can
check out the last video right here
[Music]